$97 per month for a paper newsletter
that's right we are talking about the
prestigious email players by Ben settle
and in today's video we're going to
figure out is it worth it for you stick
around let's find out but something that
is for sure worth it for you is
copyrighting catalyst it's my free
copyrighting guide that I wrote for you
the copywriter that you can actually get
for free just by clicking the link in
the description below click it put your
email in tell me where to send it and
you're going to get 63 cash cow
copyrighting tips that you can read in
90 seconds or less each so that you can
sharpen and master your copyrighting
skills either for yourself or for your
clients starting today just drop your
email below and you'll get it instantly
absolutely worth it now let's WP back
into the video disclaimer about email
players don't let my email players hack
give it away but I am a huge Ben settle
fan however he did not pay me to make
this video he has not watched this video
and 100% of my brutally honest thoughts
in this video are of my own not only
that but I've been an email player
subscriber for the last 15 months so my
review of email players is a very
extensive one after putting in what I
would consider hundreds of hours of
investment reading and studying the
material to tell you whether it's worth
your investment or not so I'm going
toing break this video out into three
sections the pros the cons and the pawns
pawns being I couldn't put them in a pro
oron because it's really based on you so
I put them in a pond and in fact we're
actually going to start with the ponds
because it is the most relative to who
you are so Pawn number one of email
players it is very personality based I.E
if you really like Ben settle and you
read his emails and you love the way
that he writes copy then yeah you're
going to love email players because it's
just a longer form version of his
already very long emails but if you're
not a big Ben settle fan which is very
possible because he's very opinionated
he's very sharp edgy he writes very
uniquely which causes a very love or
hate relationship with him Pawn number
two is that email players is completely
written I mean look at
this I've got Stacks and stacks and
stacks of this so there are no videos in
these email players this is all a 20
Page is documents usually 15 to 20 Pages
sometimes longer 30 pages but it's all
written there's no videos there never
was any videos it's all very Scrappy and
to some people they hate that they want
to consume content through video me on
the other hand I find this as a huge Pro
because I as a copywriter love to write
which means I likely love to read I'm
assuming you do as well and so I consume
most of my content through Reading it's
a lot easier for me to sit down in the
evening and actually page through
written content as opposed to sitting in
front of my computer for another hour or
so watching a video that then distracts
me to a Twitter Rabbit Hole or email
Rabbit Hole or news Rabbit Hole I can't
stand that stuff so to me it is a huge
Pro that it is written but if that's not
the way you consume content you are
going to not like emo players Pond
number three and Ben actually uses this
as a tactic to repel the wrong people
from email players and that is that
email players is more fundamentalist
than it is new and shiny information
like most goons and gurus online are
constantly trying to teach you about new
modern ways to implement strategies and
tactics and things like that Ben is a
Relentless Master of the fundamentals so
sometimes it feels very repetitive as he
repeats things over and over again with
using different stories and different
angles but it can feel like the same
thing over and over and over again
because he ruthlessly sticks to those
fundamentals to the 20-year-old kids
just coming around the block this might
piss you off and be like man teach me
something new but to those of us who
have been in business for a long time we
know that we have to rehash the
fundamentals 20 30 40 50 times for them
to actually stick and it's the
fundamentals that make the money but
that doesn't mean it might not piss some
other people off so if you're not a big
fan of just digging down deep into the
fundamentals and you more really like
the new stuff new tactics new ideas
every single month then this is not
going to be the newsletter for you and
the last Pawn is that the topic for the
email players is completely unknown
until it shows up in this month's email
players he talks about building your
luck by being ruthlessly consistent and
this one he talks about building JV and
affiliate Partnerships in this email
players he talks about how to hang
trolls and use them profitably I mean
it's just a series of unknown topics
that show up at your door and the reason
that this is a pawn instead of a pro or
a con is because the con being you don't
know what's showing up so you don't
actually know what you paid for to learn
that month the pro being is that we as
humans tend to only buy the things that
we want instead of the things that we
need and I cannot tell you how many
times a topic of email players has
showed up at my door I didn't think that
I needed it I was like oh I really don't
want to talk about funnels this month
but that's what he wrote about was
funnels and I would learn something that
would blow my mind and say wow I could
really be a lot more profitable if I
tweet just a few things that I learned
in this article and yep lo and behold
nine times out of 10 I make some tweaks
based off out of the thing he talked
about instead of the thing I wanted to
hear and I made a lot more money and
that is because Ben has been around for
such a long long time that he knows so
much more than 99% of copywriters and
business owners in this space that he is
going to give you topics that will help
you more than you understand and so even
though you may not want to read that
topic that month it might be the thing
you need to read that month all right
now let's dive into the cons con number
one is the obvious it's expensive it's
$97 per month that's a lot of money the
average American us household actually
pay somewhere in between $10 to $20 a
month for their average subscription
think Netflix Disney plus your financial
app whatever you got your average
monthly subscription is $10 to $20 a
month email players is 5 to six times
more expensive than that now we'll get
this later in the pros but obviously
email players is designed to make you
money but that doesn't take away from
the fact that it is expensive it's
almost $100 in fact it's practically
$100 and so this does deter a majority
of the people away from being able to
subscribe or even wanting and justifying
the subscription of a $97 per month
email paper newsletter but at the end of
this video I will tell you exactly who
this $97 email paper newsletter is for
but con number one it's expensive con
number two is it's not very tactical Ben
does write certain email players
newsletters that have a lot of tactics
in them very specifically I remember
April of 2024 he wrote a very tactical
email players newsletter on how to
create content he gave about 20 to 30
very specific ways to find great content
ideas for emails and videos and tweets
and all things like that a highly
tactical newsletter but for the most
part most of his email players issues
are more strategic and philosophical it
changes the way you think about your
business or it changes the way you
implement certain Strate IES in your
business I.E often times I have to read
an email players newsletter two to three
times before I fully grasp the ideas and
then I have to think how does this
tactically apply to my business this is
a con because this is work that most
people will not do but by going the
extra mile to do those things the
newsletter actually becomes
significantly more valuable and I
actually end up implementing the tactics
that I do end up finding in my mind from
the strategies he gave me below and
behold it is not a Shakur Board of 1 2 3
4 5 at least most times it is not so
take that into consideration and the
final con number three is that you can't
try it out I mean I guess you can but if
you cancel it he will Blacklist you
that's right benetto has a very hard and
fast rule that if you cancel email
players you will be blacklisted from
ever resubscribing to email players down
the line line now I know that sounds
cruel but his mentality behind this is
really really strong being that if you
didn't find it valuable the first time
and you cancel it why would you want it
back again later now I know there's the
obvious boys out here that are like
maybe I was just going through a hard
time or whatever but his justification
behind it is that email players should
be making you significantly more money
than it's costing you so it should
actually feel like an investment not an
expense and if you're not getting a
return on your investment and that's why
you cancel it that's okay he doesn't
want you back and this is an obvious
play to repel all the shiny object
syndrome gurus out here who are just oh
let me try this let me try and they
don't actually Implement anything he
wants only the best most qualified
buyers on his list but indeed it is a
con that if you're off the list you're
off forever let's wrap up with the pros
and I'm going to tell you exactly who
this newsletter is for pro number one is
that you get direct
access to Ben settle that's right you
can email him your questions and he will
respond because you are an email player
subscriber now to me I've actually
emailed Ben quite a few times probably
once or twice a month for the last 15
months I try not to blow him up but
often times I do run into business
challenges that I feel like he would be
incredibly helpful for and in fact he
has saved me and made me thousands
thousand of dollars just by simply
replying to my emails a couple times a
month because I'm an email player
subscriber this is a huge underrated Pro
of being an email player subscriber to
tap into 20 to 25 years of copyrighting
Industry wisdom it's like having access
to an incredible Mentor for am measly
100 bucks a month this alone to me is
worth a subscription Pro number two is
that the writing of email players is a
unique perspective on the fundamentals
that candidly I've never read anywhere
else so earlier when I talked about that
Ben is a ruthless fundamentalist where
that's basically where he lives the
entire time no new and shiny he does
give the fundamentals an angle a story a
perspective a look that I've never read
before and it always blows my mind
because it helps me see the fundamentals
in a different light and it helps me use
them in a different way plus they're
highly entertaining because his stories
are so good his personality is hilarious
and it's highly entertaining and again
you don't get this information anywhere
else actually that's one of my favorite
reasons it's a paper newsletter because
this is not just some PDF that you can
download and copy and he also posted on
Twitter and he also posted on his email
and he also posted everywhere no it's
only here that's it if you don't have
these babies you don't have this
information ever so it's very exclusive
it's very rare and it is very fun to
read and the last Pro is that it is
profitable if you put it to use I flip
through my email players two to three
times a month I'll reread them even if I
have one small takeaway from here and I
go apply to my business 9 out of 10
times it's going to make me more than
$100 which means that the advice in here
is profitable to you you get a return on
your investment if what you learn for
$97 whether it's 15 pages or 10 pages or
two sentences if what you learn makes
you more money it is an investment now
again granted you got to go put in the
work but if you do it will make you more
money I'm 15 months into these and every
month they've made me more money but
that's only because I fit the profile of
who this is for so let's talk about that
do you fit the profile of who email
players is for here are the three things
that I think need to make out the person
of who email players is perfectly for
the first thing is an email copywriter
if you write copy four emails then this
is perfect for you because this is email
players so all of the idea is
fundamentally attached to writing copy
for emails if you do not write copy for
emails on a regular basis then this is
not going to be as helpful for you
because you do not have an outlet to go
put the new strategies to play and make
your money back I've talked to a handful
of people who just like reading Ben's
content but they don't actually write
emails or write copy I think that's fine
but if you don't I then I think it's
more an expense than an investment
whereas for me I write an email every
single day like Ben teaches so I have 31
opportunities every single month to put
his tactics into play and make my money
back which I easily make in 2 to 3 days
so if you're not currently writing
emails whether for s for your clients or
for a business which by the way all
three of those are applicable to get a
return on your investment but if you're
not doing any of those then no I would
not suggest you sign up for emao players
the second thing I would say is if you
are a business owner I.E you run your
own personal brand maybe through Twitter
you're a YouTube You're a coach whatever
you own a business that makes money or
you have clients so you're a freelancer
I would consider that a business owner
or you run a business with employees
then all of those would make sense
because the $97 per month subscription
is absolutely nothing compared to what a
true business owner would make and then
you have so much more leverage to put
the strategies into place that you would
have a lot of compound return just based
on tweaking small things because a
business is a lot bigger of an asset to
make money with than just Joe Schmo on
Twitter who really likes Ben settle but
all he does is tweet and he doesn't have
a product he doesn't have anything to
sell he doesn't have an email list these
are not the right people to actually
sign up to this newsletter you have to
have some kind of asset some kind of
Leverage to take the strategies that he
teaches you and make your money back as
fast as possible and then lastly I would
say you have to already enjoy Ben's
emails because if you don't enjoy Ben
his personality whether it's harsh or
edgy or just really highly entertaining
if you don't already enjoy his emails
you're definitely not going to enjoy
email players but it's a huge Pro if you
do enjoy Ben his emails his personality
his opinions then it's just going to be
a page extension that's going to be
amazing to read super entertaining and
it's going to give a lot more value than
he gives credit for but that's it that
wraps us up for the whole video I hope
that was incredibly insightful to
whether you should become an email
player subscriber or not in fact I've
made it easy for you I have put the
email players hyperlink down in the
description below I do not make any
money this is not an affiliate okay this
is just me sharing this with you because
I am a huge Ben settle fan and if this
video helped you decide whether or not
to become an email player subscriber
fantastic I'm glad I could be of service
and help you do so and if you do become
an email player subscriber let me know
in the comments below shout it out i'
love to cheer you on Welcome to the
email Players Club no you do not get a
hat like this that is just for special
members of the club but you do get an
email player schema book when you sign
up look check this out so you get this
exclusively month one when you sign up
and this is the only way to get the book
is is by signing up for email players
and know you cannot buy this book any
other way it's exclusive to members but
it basically just gives his entire
Playbook of how he writes daily emails
what he does what he doesn't do it's
incredible so this is a great bonus gift
on month one but I warn you if I figure
out that a bunch of you guys off my
YouTube and my email list go and sign up
get this book and then cancel I promise
you I will kick you off my freaking
email list don't do that W ruin my
reputation but if this is good for you
you're going to love this book you're
going to love email players and I hope
that you have a ful day before you go
please like And subscribe to the channel
it means the world to me to let me know
that you want more videos on
copyrighting now tell me what else
should I review next is there a course a
book another subscription that you want
me to go test out and report back
whether it's worth your money or not let
me know and I'll do it catch you on the
next one